okay so welcome to uh what are we doing
dodge right okay so what what's gonna
happen here is there's a lot of you we
have six both yes six boats okay five
five sorry five bows and you're an
assortment of arrows so I need five
volunteers
I got no you don't want to do it you're
definitely going get up here
alright uh who else yeah okay you argue
cuz it hit you you and you all right we
got five yeah you get up here what's
your name again three Sarah Jane Lauren
Marissa all right so welcome everybody
to the field of death I picked them
because they look the wimpiest so I
don't think they're gonna do any damage
alright so we got five dingos here and
we've got one pair of goggles so you
five are going to be shooting at me and
I am supposed to dodge it got it hmm so
for the elegance of this you are gonna
be on the pitcher's mound and I'm gonna
be right here on homie everybody get up
there
line up execution-style all right
whoa nice what that was one hit you're
out already yeah okay everybody wait
tactics what style shoot all at once
I'm going alright ready wait we got one
one waiting in the wings I'll give you
one last chance one last chance that's
it that's enough
I use what arrows you got and that's it
kitchen be all cool that's trying to
kill me this isn't how this is supposed
to be I want attempt to dab my next
arrow the guys are terrible the only one
that hit me was an accident
hey I'm the best I'm great
alright anyway thank you guys okay
you're all done you're retired as
archers who's up now oh thanks for
volunteering okay give us some word
before you doing it don't hit me in the
nuts please Oh God
Martin listen to it firing squad whoa
that was so close I can't run really
high where to go is this fun Tyler I
don't like mark Kochi oh oh no no I
[Music]
don't like this
whoa
Pastor Bob somebody got me in the hand
you got him in the hand all of you
you're all winners cuz you're my team
all right Ethan you did yeah did you try
to go before we were gonna go to the
Children's right here I'm gonna give you
something at the end of this cake you
want okay do you want to play okay cool
come on he's trying to copy Jackson I
know and that's not jacksepticeye
flattens out Baker he's a faker
see that wasn't even close so what
you're gonna do is you're going to help
us and come down
a wolffish top-of-the-line yellow give
me your best top of the more than your
legs you can do it no okay I think we'll
just settle for slaughtering the
impostor
okay so we don't have an extra we don't
have an extra bowl for you but I want
you to win Easley suspecting run up and
stab them in leg with this he'll go down
yeah ready
I didn't hear anything other than time I
want you to stab him that's all I heard
okay cool
all right you're good stand on home
plate you ready go back oh you're really
fast how fast I think that'll be perfect
okay so you're gonna run with me up
there after the arrows go move out get
them ready I'm gonna go with you I'm
gonna get one of my lucky special arrows
we're gonna get him yeah what's in there
listen I'm gonna be green red is best
friends cool hi ready ringing yeah and
if you get hit in the face it'll be
amazing
gosh you're up
you can't stop either
you did that right young child so you
need to somehow redeem yourself are you
ready yeah knock
aim cheat by walking forward oh I know
you're excellent you did great so he's
not paying attention bill go go now go
now go now gonna up Oh God no one gave
me any warning yay we are all winners
except for him these are covered in
sweat I can't see you're welcome
[ __ ] are you more or less scared than
the sour challenge less now that I know
what the sour challenge is there is very
little that will fear me as much other
than maybe a butcher knife on nevermind
not going there alright so like I said
these guys are the wimpiest that I could
find and we're gonna shoot at wait who's
the wimpiest man I know um let's see
what happened you ready wait why are
they all strong looking no no no they're
very wimpy their muscles are like bark
on a tree they just fall apart and flake
you may hit me I may fall I could even
die but there will be laughter on this
day or today we celebrate your bow our
end up and the fire what you all suck on
that first volley as I expected you
would I thought really highly of you all
but this time we are going to show him
what for and who's what and where we are
where are we ah sadena Brookside Park Oh
stupid chant right hey I draw aim
whatever knew they anything
[Music]
haha none of you anticipated the moon
waiting you're pretty spry I'm like
lightning in the air remember you're
trying to hit him suppose I know you see
that face and you just have nothing but
pity but you need to let go of all your
mercifulness hit hold on to the inner
hatred in your heart
that's what markiplier is all about the
hatred in your heart what's my motto I
hate everybody we all hate each other
it's a horrible way to live
draw aim
remember the spread pattern predicts
where is gonna be I don't remember your
name camera guy we could buy dirt a lot
like negros them so that they nail me
too yeah I will nice that's good work
the bed uh hunter yeah hunter got it
Thank You hunter
Hunter was nice enough to get it to his
back which we're going to use to beat up
with you like this wet on the inside of
your glass it makes it so it seals up
nice you feel closer to all those it's
beautiful I'm gonna call you the mumbo
Jumbo's you're the mumbo Jumbo's
remember that get team shirts the mumbo
jumbo Marga bars mumbles you're gonna
get it good right I sleep Markus close
to them good excellent this will be good
this seems fair no it's coaching me I
like your crouching I'm gonna make you
springy but
yeah mom you got some of them he's just
accepting it it's really hard seeing
these they're gross
they're fog wiped them out or something
[Applause]
those gonna be in the mouth all right
good job
mumbo-jumbo you failed me dissolve the
team burn your team shirts
I am Gus up okay
all right so that was everybody uh I
don't know who won we will tally it in
the end but I think we're all winners
here right okay so thank you everybody
so much for watching which camera are we
looking at that one that one's good then
it kind of orbit around us I don't know
yeah but thank you everybody to display
here thank you everybody who's here
we're moving on to the next one so see
when we get there bye
[Music]
this is frightening all that please stop
no I hate it I hate it I'm gonna fall
I'm gonna die okay like this
Oh God okay be free